we have a very disturbing story about
the death of a young American woman in
Mexico the search for answers from the
people she was traveling with people she
says or thought were her friends
chanquella Robinson died last month at a
resort near Cabo San Lucas now Mexican
prosecutors are trying to get an unnamed
American woman extradited to Mexico to
face the charges they say that Robinson
was killed in a quote direct attack not
an accident Lilia Luciano was following
this investigation Leila good morning
the story is so disturbing on so many
levels it really is good morning to you
all well shankwilla Robinson traveled
with six friends to Mexico some of those
friends initially told Robinson's
parents that she died of alcohol
poisoning but her death certificate
leader listed her cause of death as a
spinal cord and neck injury Robinson's
father told us if it weren't for the
disturbing videos that emerged including
one where she's being brutally attacked
he fears Justice would have never been
served
do just a very you know outgoing person
I mean if you love people just love the
friends that she was around shankula
Robinson's father says his daughter's
friends are to blame for the 25 year
old's Death at a resort in Mexico in
late October days after her death a
video too disturbing to show went viral
showing a woman beating Robinson who was
naked and not fighting back while other
friends watched and filmed nearby my
daughter she suffered man and that
breath she took she suffered
and they sit there and watch a local
police report shows friends called for
medical help just after 2 p.m saying
Robinson had quote drunk a lot of
alcohol when the doctor arrived and
suggested she be taken to a hospital she
told police Robinson's friends refused
and insisted on keeping her at the
resort Mr Robinson says her friends
called shankwilla's mother that night to
say she was being treated for alcohol
poisoning an autopsy report released
Days Later States Robinson died of a
severe spinal cord injury and neck
trauma at around 3 pm after her death
all six friends returned to the United
States Mexican authorities are now
seeking the extradition of a single
female suspect John Jay College law
professor Dimitri shaknovich says the
process Now lies in the hands of the U.S
justice system they will engage in their
own due process to see this person that
is alleged to have committed a crime
should be extra day what do you want to
see happen I want the truth man I just
want them to get back over there and
tell the Mexican authorities why they
did what they did I can't even be a
grandfather I can't even walk it down
now
the only thing I can do is cherish the
moment that we had the 25 years while
she was here on this Earth
his only child Robinson's death is being
investigated by Mexican authorities as a
femicide or the killing of a woman
because of her gender the FBI has said
that they have opened an investigation
into the death as well and at this hour
it remains unclear whether those who
witnessed the fight may also be in legal
Jeopardy I hope they are I saw the video
for the first time my niece showed it
disturbing over a vacation it is so
upsetting and you can hear them yelling
at her saying fight back fight back if
the arrest warrant is for the woman who
we see in the video she needs to be sent
over to Mexico sooner rather than later
it's so outrageous and I think Dad is
right if it wasn't for that video they
might have gotten away with the story
that they initially told that was a
concern he says you know if if these
videos hadn't come come out he fears
that you know the story that these
friends had that this happened because
of alcohol poisoning which he says they
insisted and some of those friends came
to the mother's house to her family and
told that same story told all the same
story until the videos came out and then
everybody shut down their social media
disappeared and had been silent I hope
the U.S acts on this yeah oh Justice
does not get away with this exactly
thank you so much